the russian invasion of ukraine has been
going on for nearly two months in that
time period we've seen the russian army
pouring to the north south and east of
ukraine only to withdraw from the north
round kiev and hold their offensive in
the south towards odessa and more
recently ukrainians sunk the moskva the
flagship of the russian black sea fleet
we also see ukrainians counter-attacking
ground harkev in the north and herzog in
the south while russia is gearing up for
its decisive offensive in the east
naturally the question arises who's
winning to answer this we're going to be
looking at economic and military factors
on both sides influencing the outcome so
we can get a better idea of the
situation of course when following war
related events we have to exercise
proper mental hygiene to keep ourselves
afloat fabulous is an app that can help
you do that the sponsor of today's video
fabulous is your digital coach a
happiness trainer if you will it's the
number one self-care app to help you
build better habits and achieve your
goals fabulous really helped me maintain
my mental health as i keep track of
current events and helps ward off the
anxiety i get from looking at examples
of american urban planning based on
behavioral science it helps you develop
great healthy habits and routines for a
healthier more productive and fulfilling
lifestyle the app will help you create
your own rituals these small steps that
lead to big changes the two ways to use
the app are habit tracking and dedicated
programs in habit tracking you can
choose from 100 plus recommended habits
or you can create your own fabulous and
helps you build these habits with gentle
reminders and content based on
behavioral science dedicated programs
will help you achieve your well-being
goals over the course of several weeks
the new habits you pick up can be added
to your daily routine if you so choose
and god the illustrations are nice it's
one of my favorite things about the app
besides the fact that its methods
actually work with the premium version
you can build and improve an unlimited
number of habits in your routines and
you have access to all programs and
exercises start building your daily
routine the first 500 people to click
the link below will get 25 off their
fabulous subscription thank you for
checking out fabulous ads like this help
support what i do and now back to the
program
so who's winning in the russian invasion
of ukraine there are two relevant
factors to consider here economics and
military first let's look at economics
the ukrainian economy has been decimated
by the war since it's a war consequently
ukraine's gdp will basically be cut in
half this year however as
counterintuitive this might sound it's
not that big of a problem the ukrainian
population can be sustained even at half
gdp and beyond that you basically only
need money for the war effort and for
that ukraine basically has a blank check
from the west they will not let ukraine
run out of money under any circumstances
in this war ukraine's funds are for
intents and purposes infinite at no
point do they have to worry about how
they're going to pay for the war of
course this doesn't mean that they can
just spend trillions each day but they
will have a steady amount to keep them
offload coming in each month a far more
important question here is how russia is
faring on the economics front at face
value their economy isn't really faced
by the sanctions the ruble seems to be
offload having stabilized around an
almost pre-invasion level so that looks
good too bad it's complete [ __ ] so
what's going on here of a given currency
if there is more selling than buying the
currency weakens if there is more buying
than selling it strengthens so more
people seem to be buying rubles than
selling a testament to the faith in
russia's financial institutions right
not really you see russia has limited
selling and forced buying thus creating
an artificial demand which keeps the
ruble afloat for the time being the wall
street journal calls it a central bank
induced coma russia is also burning its
precious foreign currency reserves to
buy rubo or for the sake of temporary
stability with the war expenditures the
currency stabilizing and western asset
freezes the russian reserves are in
decline even as they keep selling their
oil and gas as for the stock market
russia has adopted the strategy of there
can be no stock market crash if there is
no stock market but behind the scenes
things are not looking great nonetheless
just
um
however after a month-long closure the
russian stock market reopened in late
march and the market didn't actually
crash so what happened is the russian
economy so resilient after all according
to this new york times article when the
market opened only 33 stocks out of
several hundred were allowed to trade
under heavy restrictions foreign
investors couldn't sell their holdings
as there was a blanket ban on short
selling which stopped traders from
betting on falling prices the government
had pledged to spend up to 10 billion
dollars buying shares trading was open
for about four hours each day right so
as you can see it's once again complete
[ __ ] but for now crushes foreign
currency raisers will carry the country
as things get progressively worse
nonetheless western companies are moving
out russians are set to lose their jobs
by the hundreds of thousands nationwide
inflation is at a staggering 16.7
percent and a major recession is already
underway all this means is from the
invasions perspective short term the
russian economy will be fine ish midterm
they will survive long term however
there is a technical term russia is
[ __ ] but this doesn't mean they can't
win the war economics in this case
cannot give us a definite answer to the
question of who's winning but it creates
a significant time pressure which
heavily influences the second factor
military let's start here with a simple
question how can you tell if someone is
winning a war or not it's not as simple
as who wins the most battles as a
popular well-known example in the song
of ice and fire rob stark won every
battle during his campaign but was still
set to lose the war and then he got
married the reason why rob stark lost
the war despite being successful on the
battlefield is because his goals were
unattainable given the circumstances
while tywin lannister's goals were far
more reasonable but back to the real
world what are the goals of ukraine and
russia for ukraine the fundamental goal
is to ensure the survival of the country
in its current form of government to
avoid being annexed by russia or being
turned into a puppet state this involves
holding kiev and all other major
population centers then their secondary
goal is to restore the borders before
the 24th of february 2022. their
tertiary goal is to fully take back the
donbass and crimea russia's goals on the
other hand have been far harder to pin
down since they've been shifting
constantly officially that is the latest
official goal of the russian offensive
is to eliminate the nationalists
far-right battalions in ukraine somewhat
of a step down from the original promise
namely how they will purge the
drug-addicted neo-nazis who took over
ukraine and destroyed u.s funded biolabs
that produce anthrax infected bats to be
flown into russia and bioweapons that
target russian genes i am not making
this up by the way these were all
official russian propaganda talking
points but beyond the propaganda
russia's goal was the establishing of a
pro-russian puppet state in ukraine this
involves taking kiev haruki odessa nipro
and other major cities together with the
surrounding territory so right off the
bat we can see that ukraine's first goal
was achieved does russia's goal fail
russia lost the battle for kiev and even
though russian propaganda insists that
kiev was just a clever trick to draw
ukrainians away from the east or
something yeah right go powder actually
it's even more embarrassing if the
battle of kiev really was a fake out
russia's best troops got defeated and
humiliated thousands died or got injured
hundreds of vehicles lost all in battle
against a defense force that mostly
would have stayed around kiev no matter
what but military goals can and will
shift over time following the defeat at
kiev russia had to revise its goal to
just taking the south and the east to
cut off ukraine from the sea to annex
the dumbass fully and to create a land
bridge between russia and crimea but at
this point their goal number two has
also failed though they took most of the
south they couldn't take the
strategically important part namely
odessa and mikolive what's more herson
is now assessed to be contested and will
likely be retaken by ukrainians pushing
all the way to the river the best the
russians can do there is to try and hold
their gains but even when ukrainians
take her son and start pushing towards
crimea the land bridge will no longer be
sustainable it's a flat rather dry
terrain with not much room for defense
where attacking armies can just sweep
through so russia had to once again
revise its goals they had to drop
cunning off ukraine's sea access and
shift focus from the south to the east
to try and take the dawn bass at this
point the land bridge to crimea is in
the maybe category fully dependent on
russia's success in the donbass and
there are two scenarios for the donbass
offensive the first is a major pincer
maneuver where two forces start out from
hardcave and south of zapporoja and link
paranipro taking at least the latter two
cities and cutting off ukraine's best
troops in the donbass thus eventually
forcing a ceasefire and some form of a
surrender however not even this is
plausible at this point as a reminder in
the south mariupol is still not fully
taken as of the making of this video and
every day the russians spend bug down
there the less capacity they'll have for
further offensives also mariupol is a
450 000 city kharkiv is 1.4 million
denipro is 1 million while the project
is 750 000 and they cannot even be cut
off from supply lines like mario paul
was very early on in light of the
russian army's performance so far in
urban combat i just don't see a way for
them to take any major cities beyond
mario paul and if russians don't take
act just pass it by ukrainians will use
that cdsa fortress to conduct raids out
of disrupting supply lines and harassing
passing troops so the ambitious
encircling plan is as far as i can see
dead on arrival the russian's last
possible goal is a smaller more
conservative encirclement of ukrainian
troops importantly this plan doesn't
involve taking any major cities just
advancing north and south simultaneously
from mariopol and izum performing a
smaller encirclement of ukrainian troops
in the area if russia succeeds in this
then ukraine will have failed its
secondary goal the restoration of
pre-invasion borders and russia will
have achieved at least some victory but
some might worry that at that point
russia will just dig in for a couple of
weeks gather some strength and resume
the offensive against an exhausted
ukrainian defense force except they
won't be able to this is where economics
really hit russia in the face time is on
the ukrainian side due to sanctions and
disrupted supply chains russia cannot
get modern weapons from anywhere and
cannot produce them in the needed
quality and quantity they also have to
keep financing the war effort somehow
russians have less and less money and
hardware as time goes on while
ukrainians keep getting more hardware
and don't have to worry about finances
so as things stand now i see two
possible outcomes one russia succeeds
with the small encirclement and declares
mission accomplished two ukraine halts
the small encirclement then
progressively pushes back the russian
army plagued by obsolete equipment lack
of trained personnel and low morale with
time the previously described economic
issues will also become more pressing
accelerating the russian defeat in that
case ukraine can proceed trying to
accomplish their more ambitious goals so
in summary right now we're in a
situation where ukraine can only win
having already secured its main
fundamental goal and why russia can
either win small or lose completely this
would be my current assessment of the
situation based on the facts currently
available and i haven't considered
things here such as russian tactical
nucleus or chemical weapons it's a
possibility but let's see topic for
another video in the meantime thank you
for watching and don't forget to like
and subscribe and i also have a patreon
if you think this content is worth your
money and i'll be seeing you next time